what's your explanation for the fact
that an old Brooklyn jus 74 years old
has such a gathering of fans of
thousands of thousands of functions of
Millennials who think that he will
represent the future and ultimately it's
a complicated story I mean I think that
young people are receptive to big ideas
just striking slogans to things that are
going where we're going to chill where I
have a rose your shooters educated by
you Princeton's a little different but
but but but yeah but the people that age
not my case because they've been raised
Emily but that's another story um sure I
mean look I'm a 68 or I come out of all
of that of course we want to have a
revolution of course the world needs to
be changed in radical different ways so
I understand the appeal and the age of
the person doesn't really know any
weights are changing sorry and the winds
are changing the winds were changing in
1968 logo we got okay I hope you don't
get what we got in 1968 please please
please you know please let's not have
that happen no I mean I I don't think
that that America is a revolutionary
situation at the moment I'm not quite
sure what senator Sanders means by a
political revolution it's somewhat vague
it sounds great but what does he mean he
says he's a socialist and then when you
ask them what is socialist means it
means it's a new deal Democrat well
socialism and New Deal Democrat that's
not the same thing so there's a certain
degree of lack of clarity shall we say
but what senator Sanders stands for and
what he aims to do I think what he's
pushing at is a frustration the
frustration with the current
administration because the current
administration ran in is came in with
many many young people and many
intellectuals thinking that it was going
to be the second coming of something and
it's never the second coming of anything
but that people got this very
disillusioned with him and so there's a
frustration there and it's been turned
back around I think that Hillary Clinton
suffers from all of the old stuff about
the youth of the 90s much which is
mythological being turned against her as
well when you throw in social media when
you throw in how
information is designed now I'm not
surprised that people hater or some
people claim to hate her because they've
been whipped up the same whipping up is
going on in both ends and so you see
that degree of fervent feeling out there
much of which I think what would I think
it would and will fade after the dust
settles that's my hope in anybody but I
can understand it because look 2008 was
a profound event in America and it took
a while for the political system to
respond to it it didn't become clear
because there was happy in an election
year so President Obama inherited the
situation and did the best that he could
and did a pretty good job at least of
getting things back on an even keel and
getting the economy we didn't have it
the disaster the rehab but the effects
of that the slowness of the growth since
then an entire generation of young
people saddled with great loans without
a great future out there for the way in
which the Internet has destroyed old
occupations structures the way that
everything is different than it used to
be we don't know where we're going I can
understand perfectly why people are
nervous I'm nervous you know I'm nervous
but there's a way in which you know you
have to think about how you're going to
address that that condition and there
are good ways I think solid ways to do
it and then there are their advice that
are much more in substantial and I'm
afraid I find someone who I know a
socialist who says he's a new dealer
that's not going to get me very far or
as I think that that Hillary Clinton
actually does have ways to go get us
further down the road that we possibly
could so that's why I'm supporting her
this could